Hi everyone, my name is Sai Vennam and I'm
with the IBM Cloud team.
Now, I know in previous videos we talked about
technical concepts that always relate back
to cloud-native computing in one way or another.
Now, over the years I've seen businesses harness
those concepts to create innovative solutions
to real problems.
In this era of Hybrid and Multicloud businesses
need a way to run containerized applications
in a way that they can run anywhere.
In this video I want to touch on a few of
those use cases for why a business may want
to use Hybrid or Multicloud.
Let's start with the basic one, Cloud Scaling.
Now, most of us are probably familiar with
this, it is one of the main reasons for adopting
the cloud.
Now, let's say we have a flower delivery service
that is able to hit a certain bottom line
of users. They have on-premise infrastructure
and it can hit a certain amount of user load.
So, visualizing this here throughout the calendar
year you can imagine that their load maybe
goes up and down in response to specific holidays.
Now, to hit those peaks they could scale up
their on-premise architecture but that's met
with upfront costs and cost of upkeep.
Now, instead we'll take advantage of cloud
that allows them to scale up in response to
that load and then automatically key provision
resources when they no longer need them.
Now, this concept is kind of general to cloud
computing not just Hybrid or Multicloud, but
that brings me to my next topic and here we're
going to be talking about how it can be used
to build a Composite Cloud.
So, essentially this is going to be applications
that are spread across multiple cloud environments.
So, back to the flower delivery service let's
say they have an on-premise architecture that
allows them to run three major components
of the app.
So, let's say they have the web UI, they have
some billing API's, as well as a rewards framework.
Now, let's say that this service is actually
based in the EU.
And their European customers are happy but
for their North American, or American customers,
specifically around Veterans Day or Thanksgiving
their noticing that the system is bogging
down and so they decide to take advantage
of a Hybrid Cloud or Multicloud architecture
by composing their application across multiple
cloud environments.
So, they'll take advantage of data centers
in America and essentially they've identified
that although their rewards framework can
stay on-prem in their European side they want
to move the billing and the U. I. capabilities
over. So, they'll move just those two to a
cloud platform of their choice in a North
American, or American datacenter. This kind
of allows them to scale up portions in response
to say American holidays while keeping their
EU portions individually scaled. So, in this
example the flower delivery service is able
to take advantage of scaling at a global level
by using the Hybrid or Multicloud architecture.
Next let's talk about the airline or travel
industry.
So, we can first start with an example of
Modernization.
Now, in the past we've seen that reservation
systems may have been difficult to work with
or you might have had to call in, but almost
all the airline companies now have a mobile
application. So, most of the time of actually
found that it's about in general not just
in the travel industry but eighty percent
of all enterprise applications are actually
still on-prem. This likely the case in this
industry as well.
So, in this specific example, let's say they
have a reservation system that's running on-premises,
but to create new experiences for their end
users, let's say they've created a mobile
application. That mobile app of course has
a mobile backend that's maybe running in a
public cloud and that in turn works with the
reservation service. So again, the mobile
app can hit the mobile backend that in turn
works with the reservation capabilities.
So, in this case they modernized and new user
experiences are possible, but let's take that
a step further. Now, a source for a lot of
dissatisfaction for users is whenever their
flights are delayed. So, when a flight is
delayed, they may have to re-book new flights.
The solution is almost always the same, the
traveler wants to get to his destination in
the easiest way possible.
So, what airline industries have been doing
is taking advantage of the cloud to create
maybe a recommendation feature.
So, it allows them to book new flights as
soon as the delay is recommended or as soon
as the delay has ocurred and that's going
to connect up to the mobile back in service
allowing users to be able to book flights
through their phone the second the flight
is delayed. This not only improves the bottom
line for the airline industry but leads to
happier users. So, that's one way that modernization
has been done.
Next, let's take it even a step further and
talk about Data and AI.
For Data and AI, the airline industry has
been taking advantage of lots of historical
data. So, over the decades that a company
has been around, let's say they have historical
data of when unplanned maintenance has happened
on their airline.
In fact, thirty percent of all delay time
in that in the airline industry is actually
when unplanned maintenance happens.
So, by taking advantage of let's say machine
learning or AI capabilities, they could hook
into all of the legacy data that they have,
large volumes and connect them up to machine
learning and AI capabilities.
This allows airline industries to take advantage
of predictive analytics and get insights before
errors, or before that unplanned maintenance
ever occurs. This again improves their bottom
line, leading to happier users and a more
efficient airline industry.
Now, today we talked about four major use
cases for Hybrid and Multicloud platforms.
So, Cloud Scaling and Composite Cloud in the
flower delivery service, as well as Modernize
and Data and AI for the airline industry.
Now, we really have only started to scratch
the surface of the number of use cases for
why you want to use a Hybrid or Multicloud
platform.
Now, if you like this video or have any questions
be sure to drop a like or a comment below.
Be sure to subscribe and stay tuned for more
videos like this in the future.